it just turned out to be something
really magical ben affleck and jennifer
lopez's wedding was the southern soiree
to be at
somebody's getting married
after biddeford tied the knot for a
second time on saturday the couple
capped off their wedding weekend with a
sunday barbecue e.t can confirm it also
took place at ben's 87-acre estate in
riceboro georgia jay shetty officiated
jen and ben's larger ceremony at the
groom's waterfront property and after
the a-list affair wrapped guests were
escorted by shuttle for a
post-celebration lunch
an eyewitness tells etj and matt damon's
brother kyle was spotted snapping pigs
at the perry lane hotel in savannah
before heading over to grub it's
exciting
of course the dress code was anything
but traditional we're told at the
nuptials white wasn't just a color
exclusive to the bride i always have fun
with fashion director kevin smith who
worked with ben on clerks shared some
pics and our eyewitness says everyone is
dressed in white with most women in
white dresses and gowns and most men in
white suits but the dress code features
a wide variety
naturally van and jen didn't skimp on
the details for the weekend long affair
as for wedding favors our eyewitness
says kyle's wife was in a hotel lobby
carrying custom bags a source tells e.t
wedding guests staying at the perry lane
hotel were welcomed to savannah with
goodie bags and a straw nude material
with a jb monogram in white script
before heading out kyle and his wife
were seen thanking the hotel staff for
running everything so smoothly and said
it ended up being perfect it's just a
dream come true
as for what was on the menu tons of
delicious options and we're hoping there
was lots of ice cream one of ben's
favorite desserts
ben loves our butter pecan e.t caught up
with movie exec turned local ice cream
shop owner stratton leopold who's been
serving ben for years way back when he
first dated j-lo when i did the second
picture with ben in vancouver we did
paycheck up there they were together
then the first time and she was there
with us on on sat there
and then of course together again
forever
and ben's earned a solid reputation with
town locals who have nothing but great
things to say about the oscar winner
loving amazing
and devoted chef jerome brown met ben in
2005 he says the actor doesn't order
from the menu and said he just trust him
to whip up something good what is ben's
go-to order well mostly he liked my
creole he liked my grilled vegetables
of course t-bone steak
and of course my famous fried chicken
he loved my chicken
good food and good times what could be
better congrats to ben and jen
[Music]
you